bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans cette
édition du 7 8 les invités chaque jour
rendez vous avec celles et ceux qui font
l'actualité dans les yvelines
et ce soir rencontres notamment avec
eric bouvron un metteur en scène
comédien auteur et yvelinois est décoré
lors de la dernière nuit des molières
l'équivalent des césars pour le théâtre
sur notre plateau nous recevrons
également bruno grand ciel responsable
communication des fermes de gally pour
parler des animations proposées jusqu'au
31 octobre
les citrouilles sont évidemment les
stars de la ferme pendant les vacances
de la toussaint
mais on débute donc avec un homme de
théâtre et eric bouvron le 23 mai
dernier se tenait la nuit des molières
la cérémonie récompensant tous les ans
les artistes et les spectacles les plus
de la profession les plus remarqués de
la saison théâtrale parmi les lauréats
2016 les cavaliers est tiré du roman de
joseph kessel et mise en scène par éric
bouvron un auteur comédien metteur en
scène et évinois d'adoption il est aussi
le directeur artistique de rire 78 une
association qui dispensent l'humour dans
le département mélanie poké la rencontre
et si tu as besoin de n'importe quoi je
suis là
le sait n'est ce pas au cas où la mort
viendrait me prendre au cours du voyage
que nous allons entreprendre
je lègue mon cheval géoles et tout son
harnachement en propriété entière à mon
fidèle manque
geol ne sera pas moi avoir encore aux
moeurs pourquoi le testament
au départ je pensais pas qu'on aurait à
voir
molière c'est tout les gens du métier le
public 10 à en revoir molière ont fait
pas du spectacle pour dépôt des prix ont
eux aussi ont fait ça parce que oui
c'est un cheminement et quand on était
nominé deux fois c'était assez
fantastique parce qu'on était un peu
comme on dit en anglais les underdogs
les commandes et les gens qui disent on
est outsider voilà et quand ils ont
annoncé le 1er prix qu'on n'a pas eue
je pensais en avait plus la chance sur
celui là j'ai dit bon t'es foutu et
quand ils ont annoncé le grand prix à la
fin quand je pense que sauter comme un
faux je l'attendais pas du tout et
c'était c'est comment on vient de
marquer le but de la coupe du monde
en finale je pense parce que c'est
amener quelque chose différent dans le
monde du théâtre privé qui n'est pas
toujours le canapé et les têtes d
affiche
c'était vraiment une équipe qui mène une
histoire qu'un certain profondeur dans
une manière je pense assez original
innovateur qui aura l'été n'est pas
sinon innovateur parce que je faisais
toujours ça depuis que j'étais en
afrique de même forme et vous disiez
l'afrique qu'on retrouve aussi dans
africa et bochmann vous avez
l'afghanistan dans les cavaliers la
mongolie et marco polo c'est aussi votre
marque de fabrique on va dire le monde
quand je fais des spectacles je cherche
pas qu'est ce que votre ma prochaine
pièce j'ai besoin de vivre des
expériences humaines d'abord j'adore
voyager en afrique du sud depuis petit
mes parents m'ont bercé dans le monde
des voyages des formes appelle un peu le
globe de globe-trotter mais casser les
tableaux potter tout les grands auteurs
que j'admire sont des globe-trotters ce
sont des gens passionnés par les autres
les autres pays les autres cultures
parce que je dis toujours le trésor
c'est l'autre et c'est ça que qui
m'attire quand je vous parle
si je commence à vous questionner qui
vous êtes d'où vous venez soudain c'est
vous qui devenez le trésor parce que je
vous découvre je vous devenez un monde
fantastique avec des histoires avec ce
que tu as vécu les hauts les bas donc
c'est sa onzième piocher et de raconter
ses histoires donc raconte des histoires
des autres peuples
continuant de mystère bouffe quoi ce
sont des peintres qui m'inspire qui me
qui m'aide
comment faire une mise en scène comment
utiliser mieux les lumières sur une
scène pour mettre en valeur une image ce
sont les musiques des autres qui va
nourrir les émotions dans des scènes
graphiques et textuelles
voyez donc forcément c'est tout les
harkis sont liées parce que qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on n'essaie pas juste
divertir mais d'aller au profond le
théâtre de la scène ces 7 sél à
l'intensification de la vie dans toute
sa beauté quand je joue sur scène c'est
pas moi ici à 6 devant vous c'est
c'est comme un esprit qui qui entre sur
scène et qui vit qui exprime la vie
bruno ganz elle nous a rejoints sur ce
plateau bonsoir bonsoir vous vous êtes
le responsable communication des fermes
de gally on va parler avec vous des
animations qui ont débuté aujourd'hui
pour halloween du côté des fermes de
gally alors au programme on le voit sur
le plateau une animation autour des
citrouilles
expliquez-nous qu'est ce que vous faites
avec ses citrouilles ont les creuses
j'imagine on les taille exactement les
citrouilles on les a cultivé depuis ce
printemps on les a récolté ces dernières
semaines et ces derniers jours et
maintenant on les a ramenés au niveau de
la ferme ouverte de gally à saint cyr
l'école et on accueille
les enfants avec leurs parents avec
leurs accompagnateurs pour qu'ils
s'amusent pour creuser des citrouilles
qui prennent pas à cette fête qu'on
organise depuis plus de quinze ans qu'on
appelle la fête de la citrouille
alors il expliqué nous c'est difficile
de creuser une citrouille pc alors là on
voit mais c'est du travail d'experts
j'imagine que les enfants ne font pas
aussi bien la première fois ci c'est
difficile alors c'est pas si difficile
que ça ce sont des variétés spécifiques
c'est la jack o lantern c'est une
variété qui est pas trop plein à
l'intérieur le principe est le suivant
l'enfant va chercher va choisir sa
citrouille en a comme vous le voyez de
toutes les formes de toutes les tailles
il va chercher sa citrouille
généralement avec un marqueur avec un
feutre
il va dessiner la forme qui va vouloir
creuser et pour des questions de
sécurité
ce sont des animateurs de la ferme qui
vont en taille et coupées selon les
traits dessinés par les enfants on va
ensuite enlevé le haut de la citrouille
et les enfants vont creuser tout
l'intérieur avec une grande cuillère à
soupe ils vont creuser tout l'intérieur
enlever tous les pépins toutes les
fibres qu'il y a et ils vont installer
la bougie et repartir chez eux avec la
citrouille qu'ils ont choisi qu'ils ont
dessiné qu'ils ont creusée alors celle
qu'on a sur le plateau et qu'on peut
voir c'est fait par des professionnels
c'est pas des enfants parce que là c'est
quand même d'un certain niveau celle ci
est a été faite par guillaume un des
animateurs de un des animateurs de la
ferme
mais ce qu'il faut surtout c'est avoir
de l'imagination
on n'est pas obligé de suivre le schéma
classique de exactement fait peur ou
îles et les enfants les jeunes enfants
font des choses souvent très arrondi
avec des yeux très rond une bouche année
très bon ou la citrouille est plutôt
sympathique avenante et puis il y en a
qui sont un petit peu plus déluré qui
vont s'amuser à leur faire des grandes
dents et il ya plein de petites
techniques qui permettent par exemple
sur les dents d'enlever la peau de la
citrouille comme salade en ressort en
blanc donc il faut faire preuve
d'imagination se laisser aller et tout
est possible mais si accessible à tous
si pour les enfants de quel âge à quel
âge les adultes aussi peuvent s'y
si et si alors nos généralement on
accueille des enfants qui ont entre 3 et
12 ans d'accord mais si les adultes vol
veulent creuser leur site web
citrouilles pardon ils sont bien sûr les
bienvenus mais dès 3 ans il faut arriver
à dessiner les le nez les yeux la bouche
et puis après ça ça fonctionne vous
disiez tout à l'heure que les enfants
avec une cuillère retire tout ce qu'il y
a à l'intérieur de la citrouille
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait ça après là
c'est le côté pratique c'est on le jette
à la poubelle ça peut servir à autre
chose alors on l'enlève parce que c'est
un fruit un fruit j'avais dire très
naturel la citrouille est un fruit la
citrouille est un fruit donc on retire
tout l'intérieur de manière à ce que une
fois découpées et creuser elle se
conserve le mieux possible ce qu'on peut
faire de l'intérieur c'est le mettre sur
son compost et puis ça va ce va se
dégrader ça va se dégrader et permettent
de faire du compost qu'on utilisera au
printemps prochain pour m pour mettre
dans son jardin alors l'occasion d'une
telle animation c'est forcément de se
retrouver en famille que les enfants
s'amusent
est-ce que c'est aussi l'occasion de me
découvrir la citrouille finalement à
free qui est qui et qui est mal connu
juste on va dire quelques jours avant le
wind mais qui est mal connu sa
production alors qu'on peut tout à fait
parler de la production de la citrouille
avec les animateurs qui vont accueillir
tous ces enfants durant ces six journées
parce que toutes ces citrouilles elles
viennent de chez nous c'est nous qui les
avons
fait pousser on au printemps on installe
la citrouille c'est une plante qui
craint le froid ans en avril m et puis
on la récolte entre fin septembre et
début octobre
et puis on a un champ de citrouilles on
a ajouté imaginé à la chaude on a un
champ de citrouilles chaque nous on
parle de la graine dans nos serres on va
planter on va planter les graines dans
du terreau et après on prend ces petites
meutes avec un petit plan de citrouille
a commencé à se développer on va
l'installer dans les chambres le plan de
citrouilles va se développer pendant
plusieurs mois
et quand ça arrive à maturité laplante a
tendance à sécher il reste plus que tout
ces boules orange toutes ces centaines
milliers de citrouilles on cultive plus
de 4 hectares de citrouilles aux fermes
de gally
donc on a des desgrandchamps qui sont
remplis de citrouilles et après c'est un
gros boulot à ramasser alors à noter
qu'avec votre ticket atelier citrouille
on peut aussi visiter la ferme visiter
les animaux puisque la ferme de gally ce
n'est pas uniquement jusqu'au 31 octobre
c'est très cette animation citrouille
c'est plein d'autre chose effectivement
crainte les enfants et leurs parents
rentrent à la femme ouverte pour suivre
cet atelier dans le tarif d'entrée bas
ils ont accès à toute la ferme toute la
ferme de gally il ya les vieux tracteurs
il ya la centaine d'animaux que que l'on
présentait au public il ya nos parcours
de découverte de la biodiversité locale
dans le bois de gally temps qu'il ya
mille à une découverte à faire autour
des insectes autour des animaux sauvages
qu'on peut aussi faire de la de la
cueillette à la ferme de gagner encore
aujourd'hui c'est possible on peut
encore bien surveillé à cette époque
alors actuellement à la cueillette il ya
des pommes
il ya plein de
citrouilles celle ce type de citrouille
qui sont des citrouilles que l'on va
creuser mais également plein de
citrouilles qu'on va pouvoir manger un
dépôt team des potimarrons la sucrine du
berry on a plein de 22 variétés de
courges qui sont à la disposition des
gens il ya des pommes de terre il ya des
carottes
il ya encore pas mal de productions de
légumes d'automne d'hiver alors fruits
légumes et et puis aussi des fleurs on
peut cueillir des fleurs à la ferme de
gally alors c'est alors sais pas si
c'est la période annoncée ce n'est que
dans six mois la période maintenant non
la cueillette ouvre traditionnellement
avec la culture de tulipes au printemps
et elle se termine avec la citrouille et
des pommes
alors toutes les informations sont à
retrouver sur votre site dont je ne me
rappelle plus excuser les fermes de
gally point com merci beaucoup bruno
gansel de nous avoir accompagnés pour ce
7 8 invités c'est la fin de cette
édition replay sur notre site internet
tv fil 78 points comme et nouvelle
édition demain à 18h45 à demain